now from Stratford Hall Plantation the
birthplace of robert e lee author Roy
Blount jr. discusses his new biography
of the Confederate General this public
lives feature runs just under an hour
it's my privilege today to introduce our
speaker Roy Blount Jr who is the Decatur
Georgia Georgia native he received his
BA from Vanderbilt in 1963 and a Masters
of Arts from Harvard in English in 1964
I served in the Army from 1964 to 1966
he's been a reporter and columnist with
the Atlanta Journal from 1966 to 1968
and from 1968 to 1975 he has been a
staff writer for Sports Illustrated
since 1975 mr. blunt has been a
freelance writer living sheep chiefly in
western Massachusetts he's contributed
to over a hundred publications including
New Yorker Esquire Atlantic and the New
York Times this robert e lee's study
that you've received today is his 17th
book others include first hubby and
memoir entitled be sweet about three
bricks shy of a load a year with
pittsburgh steelers an anthology
entitled roy blunts book of southern
humor and several collections of his own
humorous pieces including one organized
around the carter administration years
called crackers mr. blunt
is also a columnist for the Oxford
Americans and he's now putting together
a collection of these columns and other
pieces about the sets and in addition
he's doing now research for a short book
about New Orleans many of you also might
know him for his appearances on A
Prairie Home Companion and he is
appearing somewhere regularly
as a panelist on the weekly NPR news
quiz show wait wait don't tell me
last year PBS Rani's documentary about
going down the Mississippi River called
the main stream without any further ado
I'd like to turn this over to our
speaker
Rory Blount jr. thank you Judy always
wondered what further adue actually
consists of we always hear about it I
never actually nobody ever actually does
any further ado I appreciate the
introduction last night I got introduced
in New York and somebody said I'd read
the book about Pittsburgh Steelers
called about three brides shy of the
load which sounds more interesting
actually the bricks that sounds way
Chatillon I was asked by this there's a
series called penguin lives sometimes
people say penguin lives which is not so
it throws the whole thing off tracked
penguin lives which has been a series of
biographies of iconic figures by various
authors various writers messed up with
interesting matches Larry McMurtry did
Crazy Horse and and somebody else did
Prust somebody else who didn't talk but
that's awful say somebody else I know
they did preusse who did Edmund white
get proof and they came to me and said
would I do
Mark Twain which sort of made sense but
it made too much sense early for me I'd
written a bunch about Mark Twain already
and I didn't really want to write
anything more at the moment so shot in
my boat for the time being at least with
regard to Mark Twain so they said well
how about some other southern icon and I
said well how about to stop top of my
head I said how about robert e lee when
you think southern icon you think robert
easily
who falls somewhere in between Crazy
Horse and Proust I think excited exactly
where was my job to make that placement
in sometimes closer to proof than the
Crazy Horse and I think about it but
we'll get to that later
being here is actually so throwing me
off because I keeps making me think
about little Bobby Lee he he was less
than four years old when he left here
he's born here but lived here only
slightly less than four years I guess
and nobody knows very much about that
period of his life
one story family story is that he as
they were leaving this house the family
he asked to run back inside and say
goodbye to the Angels who are in the
fireplace there's and I never I had this
picture of sort of angels on the side of
the fireplace but I looked at Steve gave
me a wonderful tour today of the
building and the grounds and I went to
the room there where the angels at the
fireplace were and the fireplace is
really low and the angels are way down
here they're little bitty cherubic heads
and all of a sudden I had a sort of
chill as I put myself in the place of
little Bobby Lee saying goodbye to those
little angel heads in here this is
probably the place this house where
little Bobby Lee was selfish and put it
others put his needs ahead of other
people's needs for the last time
so for a few lapses later on through
life but you know everybody when they're
a baby is selfish so presumably he was
selfish as a tiny child but it's hard to
picture him being selfish because he was
such a model of self-control and
self-denial which is sort of a hard way
to live one there two a couple of things
that made me want to write about Robbie
one was the
I knew that Robert Penn Warren great
writer complained about said nobody can
write anything interesting about robert
e lee because he's too perfect
he's smooth as an egg you can't get a
grip on him maybe that's why I wore this
baseball tie which shows how you get
various grips on the baseball they
didn't seem to be any seams to robert e
lee so you couldn't get a grip on him
i'd seem to be a challenge worth taking
up and also i would to have there's not
a little epigraph one of my little
epigraphs at the top of the book one of
my favorite lines in southern literature
which is at the end of Flannery O'Connor
story a good man is hard to find as a
character called the misfit who with his
sidekick
Bobby Lee is in the course of shooting
to death a family of five or serial
killers and it probably doesn't seem
funny at all without the whole context
of the thing but it's a horrible but
also funny story if you know planning of
Connor you can see how to be possible
they're shooting people and at one point
the sidekick says some fun huh and the
misfit says shut up Bobby Lee it's no
real pleasure in life see I put that at
the epigraph of the book along with
robert e lee's statement that it is well
that get it exactly right it is well
that war is so terrible or we should
grow too fond of it Robert Easley at
Fredericksburg shut up Bobby Lee it's no
real pleasure of life misfit infinity
O'Connor's a good man is hard to find
it's easy that robert e lee well that
seems me I mean Robert Lee didn't seem
to get a whole lot of pleasure out of
life I mean there are lots of there's
scattered moments when he seemed to be
enjoying himself but he said after the
war Civil War that he his greatest
mistake in life was getting a military
education his his father and his brother
older brother Carter got to go to
Harvard and but by that by the
bobby was ready for college his father
had wasted the family fortune and there
was no money to go to Harvard so he got
an appointment to West Point so he was
in a profession that he was good at but
didn't really want and he wound up
fighting for a confederacy that he
didn't really approve of didn't want to
have didn't want didn't agree with
secession and yet he broke his health
and devoted the last years of his most
of the last years of his life to
fighting for a cause that he believed in
only because it sprang from the
countryside from the state that he grew
up in so he was bound he was and he was
always doing the dutiful thing to make
up for his father who had ended up a
bankrupt probably always felt that he
owed things to people old and I wanted
to try to figure out where that came
from exactly everybody talked about the
fact that Light Horse Harry Lee had been
a great hero in the Revolutionary War
and it had a lot of fun the
Revolutionary War as Wars go which is a
big as big as but was lots of fun at
least the way Harry taught it he would
have me be surrounded he and three or
four men would be surrounded in a
farmhouse about hundreds of redcoats and
they would keep the Hold'em at bay and
then Harry would run outside and say hey
here come the reinforcements and just
imaginary reinforcements and British
would spook the British and they would
run away and he was always pulling off
these great raids and and capturing
great bodies of British soldiers and
losing only having only one Mandic
wounded it was a kind of the war that
was hard to fault in principle and it
was a war in which not all that many
people got killed but after the war
Harry became a real estate speculator
and
blew the family fortune and blew the
family name the leaves were an old
distinguished name more than
distinguished super distinguished name
in American history in Virginia history
and Perry - sort of shot at all in one
generation he you know he bounced checks
and he didn't pay back loans and I mean
famous story is that he came over to the
neighbor's house a lot of things in this
story I don't understand is how he got
to the neighbor's house but he right
Harry went over to the neighbor's house
and asked to borrow a horse and the
neighbors not only lent him a horse but
sent another horse with him with a slave
so that he wouldn't have to ride the
first horse back the slave could ride
back with a one horse and lead the other
horse home and the slave was gone for
weeks and weeks and finally he returned
on foot and in terrible condition and
they said what happened to the two
horses and he said mr. Perry sold them
and they said well why didn't you just
come back home directly he said mr.
Harry sold me to little lot stories the
Antebellum stories that they write harry
messed up the family name to the point
where Bobby Lee felt he had to be
perfect we all know much about his
mother who was a beautiful woman
all we know is one I believe I mean
anybody who knows more about this and I
do please speak up but far as I know
there's only one portrait of his mother
and and she was abandoned by Harry went
off probably I mean I you can speculate
pretty loudly that probably the most
vivid memory of his father that robert e
lee had was of a broken beaten man
coming back from having been beaten
nearly to death and in fact having his
nose nearly cut
Harry Lars Harry went down to Baltimore
to help a friend of his a newspaper
editor defend his newspaper against mobs
and they all got surrounded by a mob and
mob broke in and they adjourned to the
jail with their pistols and then the mob
surrounded the jail and at that point
Light Horse Harry suggested that he and
all the other supporters of this
newspaper mend all these gentlemen shoot
each other rather than to die at the
hands of the rabble but he was voting on
that and so they didn't see each other
but the mob got in and beat them all
there he has to kill one on my believe
and there was a stack of about six or
seven men Federalists defenders of this
newspaper on the jailhouse floor and the
mob went around poking them with with
pocket knives and dripping candle wax
into their eyes to see if they were
still alive so they could kill him and
they even went to Italy and tried to cut
his nose off and and foxes slashed his
now as you all know the Lino's was a
distinguished feature for anybody to
make so bold as to try to cut one off as
pretty astonishing any lead to allow his
nose to be handled in such a way was was
extremely humiliating
so robbery Lee was five years old when
his father came hobbling home all beaten
and broken and black in the face in his
face all horribly scarred and shortly
thereafter Lighthorse Harry went away to
the Bahamas where he stayed for the rest
of his life until he finally got back to
Florida at the last but the last time
robert e lee saw his father his father
was in its own shape and it seems to me
you know the thing about robert e lee is
that people do think of him as such an
icon for a long time he was an icon
after the Civil War he was an icon
representing national unification and
everybody getting back together
North and South agreeing that robert e
lee was a great man one thing we can
agree on robert e lee is a great man now
things have shifted the point where
lots of people associate robert e lee
with with honor and integrity and
dignity and on the other hand lots of
other people associated him with slavery
and treatment his you all know about
this I'm sure but it's his portrait
honor it in Richmond was defaced and
torn down and there's been all sorts of
all sorts of outrage directed toward him
it always seems such a shame because
essentially when I was down there
looking that those'll angels that little
Robert looked at and said goodbye to as
a child here from this house it seems a
shame that he became such an icon I and
he didn't like attention he would never
have been making this speech I mean he
had made his speech it would be much
more dignified this one but he didn't
make speeches he didn't like to call
attention to himself and yet he was
described by lots of men and women as
the most beautiful person they ever saw
I think he was it he in everybody thinks
of him is this gray bearded gray-haired
gray uniformed man on the gray horse but
in fact he was as a younger man he
looked a lot like Cary Grant I keep
trying to find a more contemporary
example because people probably don't
remember what Cary Grant looked like now
but his brother Smith in the only
portrait I've seen looks remarkably like
Kagan but robert e lee until the war was
one of the best-looking people anybody
ever saw he didn't have the beard he was
had a great mustache and great long nose
and and he was about 5 foot 11 and he
also had tiny feet that's another thing
that made me want to write about robert
e lee I saw Emery Thomas on who's the
definitive biography of Ivy League every
Thomas on c-span being interviewed and
he mentioned that Robbie Lee wore a size
4 and 1/2 C boot I have struggled to try
to bring that into perspective
I have some comparisons in here Faulkner
who was only about thoughts William
Faulkner is only about five to put six
or something more on seven didn't ask
you I believe and I had one I had in my
original draft of this book in
comparison which was regarded and so
appallingly indecorous by the editors of
England editors that I finally gave up
and took it out which was that robert e
lee had the same size feet as pauline
kael the film critic of the New York The
New Yorker who was about five feet tall
and she would happen to know that
because she knew Paulina and she wore a
five and had ladies five and a half
which is I gather on pretty good
authority is the equivalent of a men's
for but for a five foot eleven men to
wear such a small shoe seems remarkable
and I've kept wanting to make something
out of it I mean there are several
little things about robert e lee that
all of our first mentioned but then they
just move on i said wait a minute how
about the little thief how does a man
carry himself that was as it affect a
man to have such little feet also
beautiful feet apparently according to a
subordinate officer who picked him up
after traveler threw him down during
civil war he landed on his hands and
broke both of his wrists and which also
leads to interesting speculation didn't
it and and that the officer says the
time that he had the most beautiful
hands and feet I don't know why he saw
he can see why he saw his hands because
I don't know how people were always
saying things like that about Robby Lee
he's got the most beautiful feet he's
got the most beautiful face it's a
remarkable thing for a man a military
man to be singled out as so so beautiful
grant ulysses s grant robbery leader
that you old nemesis was called beauty
at West Point because he was such a rosy
cheeked sylphlike little man
he and his sister-in-law later called
him a perfect little doll or something
like that and he he was so pretty that
in fact he grew heavy coarse beard and
developed a slash and took up drinking
whiskey which nearly destroyed his
career and smoking cigars all the time
was kill me people will men will
sometimes go to great lengths not to
look for it but robert e lee who
possessed a more manly sort of beauty
clearly prides himself on his appearance
though he probably would never admitted
he you can tell he prided himself on it
because one thing he kept it up so well
everybody all talking about how perfect
if you perfect he looked and also he
wrote a letter to his daughter after he
started going to Greybeard during the
war talking - telling his daughter how
ugly he had become you know and you can
sort of sense behind that how pretty he
realized he had been but he would never
have prided himself on his appearance
except by keeping it up as if he owed it
to everybody else to look good but he
was not in other ways he was he's an
interesting gender issue because he
didn't like hanging out with men he
preferred the company of women
he went to West Point where is
surrounded by men and he was in the army
where he spent most of his life with
nothing but men but what he loved was to
go to balls and gossip with bells about
their bows he he grew up in the
household with his mother and sisters
and he had four daughters of his own and
he also had three sons but he loved
being with women he loved to sort of
chat and gossip and and he was beautiful
and yet his life was has never been
described as beautiful and was sort of
grumpy and and where he was picking
span's used apparently a not very good
housekeeper and I mean they had seven
children so they clear
you know but they you don't you know I
sort of read about other people's
marriages I read about George
Washington's marriage to Martha Martha
was no stunning beauty but it was clear
you get you read any notes about how
about George and Martha out riding and
being affectionate and kidding each
other enjoying riding together and I
just never found anything like that
about the about the leaves even and yet
on end robert e lee kept writing
extremely flirtatious letters to all
sorts of cousins and young women and
brides of officers and wrote one long
letter about to one young lady that he
was that he found extremely appealing in
which he had just gotten married and he
wrote her a letter speculating about her
wedding night and saying did you go off
like a firecracker son like that
it's all very sort of startling in fact
and then at the end mary mrs. Lee writes
a little note saying we hope you all
come visit you know that is so she's
read the whole thing
it's a it's a very strange thing that he
loved sort of abstract romance which is
not a very alas and not a very masculine
trait I'm sure Willie wish that men did
like abstract romance but several women
I mean people women always thought he
was beautiful too but a couple of
different women said mentioned how
distant he was and how somebody's wanted
Custer's life I think said he's a great
looking man but I never wanted to throw
my arms around all these things to me
indicate how elusive a figure he is and
how easily usable he was as an icon
because there was so you know it because
his humanity was sort of back in the
background it's sort of hard to you know
he didn't make George Washington nearly
destroyed his career by falling in love
with a married one
and but you can't you never imagine
ideally doing that you know going often
some passionate ill-advised sort of
romance he would also the passionate
ill-advised sort of war of course but
that's another thing all those things
make him hard to relate to one thing
that also appealed to me about him is
that he reminds me of my father who was
more accessible than robert e lee but
also you know i guess everybody's daddy
is a little bit inaccessible at least to
the boys and my father was a sort of
distinguished dignified member of the
community who whom everybody sort of
looked up to and everybody expected a
lot of him and he worked himself to
death for the community and died when he
was 60 years old
one thing I achieved in my life is to
live longer than my father well by
giving much less to the community but my
father was a sort of you know less
graceful than Robert everybody was less
graceful literally I keep looking at
robert e lee fearless grizzled
dpad man and thinking about their little
kid looking at the little angels and
leaving this wonderful house that his
father had frittered away and it's just
hard to find the connection i it's
really tacky to indulge in psychology
with regard to robert e lee there's a
correspondence between Allen Tate and
Robert Penn Warren Allen Tate's talking
about writing about robert e lee and
their agreeing and these letters back
and forth
you should warren says to take you
should yes you should write this because
it shouldn't fall into the wrong hands
we don't want anybody applying the
Oedipus complex to lead why not it's my
reaction actually I don't know anything
about the elephants complex but I do
know I read a book called the drama of
the gifted child
which is about it was a very popular
book I think it back in the 90s I guess
80s maybe because I think all people who
picked it up thought oh I was a gifted
child this should be about me but in
fact it's about children whose ironic
gifts from their parents is being
expected to take care of their parents
so they don't really have a childhood so
they're expected to be perfect and
expected to be the parent of their
parents and I think that applies
throughout really I think that he was
left with his mother you know his father
went off and left him and he became when
Robert went off to West Point his mother
said what would I do that Robert he is
son and daughter to me another little
gender reference but I think he was also
almost spouse to her you know he was the
only man in the house and he was always
looking after her and nursing her and
trying to cheer her up
I think the robbery lead didn't have a
childhood
yeah maybe right after that moment when
he was kneeling by the fireplace looking
at the little angels and if anybody went
to heaven that was robbery Lee and I
hope he met those little angels when he
got up there he didn't like any
questions
his father was 50 something right it is
late in life because his father fought
the Revolutionary War long time for his
father had had one family already
including a Black Horse Harry Lee who
also disgraced apparently and Robert Lee
Ely was the last child of this second of
the second marriage so his father was
well up in years but his father spent a
number of years abroad in the island in
the Bahamas wandering around and but he
never recovered from that beating that
he got there to Baltimore oh yeah
why Square your commission he made it
for heaven connection with the
Confederacy and the vision ah well yeah
well you know it was uh well of course
there you go Rob Robert E Lee wrote a
letter to his wife in which he said he
was against slavery I think it's
probably a good idea for each of us if
there's anything going on now that we
want to make clear to posterity we were
against write a letter to your spouse
about it you won't get in any trouble
and you'll have an old record that you
were against it but he also said that he
thought the slavery was harder on the
white race that owned the black race
which seems a little dubious now but he
was a big real white man's burden sort
of guy he was not good at telling men
what to do that's one of my theories not
just my theory he and that included
telling slaves what to do and the time
he was not he was only sort of
marginally involved in slavery because
he's in the army
and but he was inherited his
father-in-law's slaves and during the
Civil War he was freeing his
father-in-law's slaves legally the while
he was fighting for the slave system he
was working through all the legal forms
to get his father-in-law's slaves freed
legally free because his father-in-law
had left it in his way
that his slaves be freed within five
years after he died that's one thing the
Virginia gentleman did back then was and
had the use of their slaves all their
lives and then put it in their will that
their that their heirs had to free the
slaves it seemed via kind of in lots of
times sometimes there's refused to do it
and that was the kind of gradual
emancipation that lots of Virginia
gentlemen including robert e lee
claiming to believe in or said they
believed in back in there but it's hard
to find out how a gradual emancipation
would have worked yeah I mean robert e
lee fought my I'm from the south and my
position is that we started the war and
we were wrong and we lost I think we all
just accept that and move on but it
wasn't that simple
of course there wasn't as if senators
were like being evil and like doing evil
things to white Southerners doing even
evil things to back so there's it was a
it was the economic system it's like
giving up slavery was so like giving up
the stock market would be today we
sometimes I think would be a good idea
but that's how little I know about
economics so it was a it was hard to
figure out how to give up slavery not
only in the South but in the north the
whole economy in American economy was
dependent to great ingredients lavery so
it's not a simple thing to give up and
in fact lots of people lots of
southerners got so got their backs up
overhearing northern abolitionists talk
about how evil slavery was that the lots
of southerners decided it was good you
know by god you'll tell me it's evil I'm
gonna tell you it's good so good for
everybody works on everybody good you
know and at least robbery leave didn't
say that he he didn't like it but he
didn't know he said it it presents the
he said giving up slavery ending slavery
presents a big problem which was what
shall we do with the freed people Robby
Lee always referred to slaves as the
people
your people over there at the planet X
he referred of course to Union troops
and referred to Union troops and Yankees
in general I think it's those people you
know in the which meant that you know
Gettysburg Address was about the
government of those people by those
people and for those people
Robbie Lee you know was fighting for the
slave system now you can say it's about
tariffs you know if you say the Civil
War was not like slavery it's like
saying that the Clinton attempt to
impeach Clinton was not about sex I mean
come on he was you know but I mean it
wasn't that simple I mean the the
tariffs there also had to do with
terrorists but the Paris had to do with
the slave system so but he fought for
Virginia and that's just the way it is I
mean I can't think of anybody who there
you know grant was everybody every white
person back then was by today's
standards every white person I've ever
read writing about race in 19th century
was by today's standards are racist I'm
including grant for instance in Lincoln
you know I mean they all said things
that they you would lose your job today
if you said them you know so I don't
feel defensive about Robbie Lee I think
he was on the wrong side and that's just
one more well I mean he presented of
course there's one more burden on him
and that's a little unfair to the slate
that's too hard to be fair to sláinte
towards the end of the war there was a
notion that the Confederate Army should
draft the slaves free the slaves to
fight in the army that there was a and
Lee was on the side of that he thought
that the slaves ought to have a chance
to fight for the south and if they
thought well they would get be free
after the war which is one interesting
thing about that is that the the Civil
War enslaved the Confederate troops I
mean they were
or while they were fighting to repel the
invaders and for the glory of it and
everything but after a while they were
fighting because they had to you know if
they if they were conscripted and the
ordinary soldiers were then shot if they
deserted which they did in great numbers
and lots of them got shot and they were
horribly equipped and and had suffered
all sorts of terrible hardships and got
mowed down in enormous numbers it was so
the war enslaved a lot of white people
as well as the people who were known as
slaves so it was just a big mess
altogether I think and it and then when
it was over I think that Bobby Lee was
used you know after the war the whole
reconstruction thing arose which was an
attempt to bring black American
african-americans up to the give them to
all the opportunities of citizenship
that white Americans had and it just did
not take it was resisted in the south
and north lost interest in it I wrote a
little thing about Mark Twain you know
in 1876 the deal was made between
Rutherford B Hayes and the Democrats and
the Republicans so that Hayes became
president and reconstruction was ended
and Rob and Mark Twain resisted politics
at the time but he never said anything
about the end of Reconstruction whereas
he was he'd run very novel about about
slavery but nobody seemed to care about
the end of Reconstruction at the time
except for Frederick Douglass who said
to the Republicans are you abandoning it
abandoning us in these pretty much said
yes so bayonets and as coming out of
Reconstruction robert e lee served a lot
of serve the purpose i think of making
everybody forget about slavery everybody
thinking about you know the bringing
together of both the north and south
which they miss white north and white
south and
me that robert e lee's been used in lots
of ways that he would deplore because he
didn't like being a figure i don't think
i mean he he was a figure you know he
looked great on the horse and but you
just never had to sit he always somewhat
one of his aides said he was never
comfortable unless he was uncomfortable
he would want to sleep on the rockiest
carter they would pitch the tent on a
nice soft spot he knows let's move it
over here where it's like even traveler
his great horse beautiful horse had a
really choppy gate to parently a really
uncomfortable to ride robert e lee
junior didn't like riding travelers this
the lee always seen their this kind of
hair sure thing but lots of other people
derived pleasure and inspiration from
him and one of the things that the whole
country derived was a sort of you know
we have two images for a long time there
were two images of coming out of the
Civil War which is Abraham Lincoln
freeing the slaves and robert e lee
uniting north and south by his
graciousness and dignity and refusal to
continue the animosity and both of those
images have been challenged from various
directions but and now i mean people
don't want to say any more than Lincoln
freed the slaves they want to say that's
lazy they don't free themselves I don't
know but Eric
they had these the country had those
images to go by which kept people from
having to think much about slavery until
maybe the civil rights movement yeah I
realize these are different sections of
the compare researching preparing for
both
three bricks I love comparative
anecdotal yeah research three bricks
I've loaded by hanging out with the
Pittsburgh Steelers and drinking quite a
bit back then I could do that I could
remember things drunk that I can't
remember now so but and I had a
wonderful
and this was lots of reading obviously
mostly and and it branched out a whole
lot more than the scenes though the
Steelers branched out to but in fact for
is the Steelers had a great defensive
back Mel Blount who now in the national
in the Football Hall of Fame I went down
and with him to say he's from South
Georgia and I'm up the blunts not blond
sir from North Florida so we figured we
had roots some kind of common roots and
I went down there we tried to research
it and couldn't find couldn't really
trace it back but we did I didn't find
out a lot of great family stories about
know the other side of Mills family Erie
just about anything I've ever written
about in fact comes down to things like
that eventually it gets down to
something you know I was like when I was
a in puberty and growing up it was the
civil rights movement and the brown
version and integrating schools and
civil rights movement all this stuff
that was my foremost 400 years that's
why what's going on when I was at
Vanderbilt there was a militant civil
rights movement they were sit-ins going
on in Nashville and I was writing
editorials advocating integrating the
student body aver the bill and basically
everything I write about seems to come
down to things like that
and certainly that was one of the things
interest me about obviously yeah one
things I wanted about was whatever
happened to those the slaves that Lee
was freeing during the war you know he
was filling out all these things get
write letters home talking about and
then a couple of slaves escaped and he
were he worried about everybody were he
worried about where the escaped slaves
were whether they would have the right
papers if they tell you he wanted to
have the right papers I mean he was a
fussy person in lots of ways he's a
fussy parent you know I would I think
he's probably the only great man in
American history in any history who
wrote more letters to his Cho
they wrote to him he's always complained
write letters during the war the
children say why don't you ever like me
I forgot where I was going to I wonder
whatever happened to those those slaves
and I saw I went to the American some
reference American history book and
looked up all the leads since the Civil
War and I couldn't find anybody you
could tell came from those slaves but
the there was Georgie and Julia Lee who
were Kansas City jazz pioneers George
was a prominent bandleader and jr.
leaves the singer of spicy songs like I
didn't like it the first time but oh how
it's grown old me which pretends to be
about Spanish but isn't and and then
there was Ulysses Grant Lee Jr Ulysses
Grant Lee jr. born in Washington DC in
1913 he went on to become an educator
and co-editor with sterling Brown of the
Negro Caravan for many years the
standard anthology of african-american
writing in an Army officer who wrote the
definitive study of the distinction
achieved by and the discrimination
practiced against African American
troops during World War two that's the
last line in the book but you know
Robbie Lee after his mother's death took
one of those one family retainer slave
who was really sick and I really took
him down with him to his first Army
assignment and some horrible little
islands in there and and nursed this old
black man and in his dying days so you
know I mean he was he was part of the
slave system but he was also a nice man
he can be there are lots of
contradictions and oxymorons in American
history and the American present that's
one
but yeah I was people in fact somebody
asked the other day what who I thought
today was like robert e lee and the only
person I can think sort of a comparable
figure American Life is Colin Powell it
was a sort of blameless kind of military
figure who doesn't believe in war but
gets involved in them and and I was
loved to have seen him portrayed in the
movies better than he has been in that
the Gettysburg he's portrayed by Martin
Sheen who was really good as a serial
killer early on in his life and the
really good as a president in West Wing
but he does not look like property
League one thing there's this moment
where he sort of glorying and being
cheered by by his troops are strutting
on this one thing he looks telly on the
horse
he's short on a horse I mean he was tall
the horse because his legs were short of
the trolleys true motions height as his
trunk look great on the horse look
better on the horse than Eddie Arcaro
but nobody remembers anything I care
only morning all good
but oh but so I went to see gods in
generals home because I figured finally
I would do volley Romney leaves and I
looked up all the people have ever
played robbery in movies and several of
them have been people you never heard of
and you know this thing IMDB the
internet movie database that will list
you look up robert e lee it will tell
you all the people ever played well
really certainly then you go look up
them and they never did anything else
that they were jesus and some other
jesus passing through some other movies
but but a Robert Duvall I thought really
had a shot at doing it right but in Gods
and Generals but one thing Gods and
Generals is just so boring gays burger I
thought that movie no the novelist based
on was good I never had the novel gods
in general but I just do
Gods and Generals is four hours long and
I lasted for the first half and during
that time Robert Duvall looked good on a
horse but he didn't have much to do
and Thomas just tell me doesn't have
much to do in the second half either so
it's a shame I'll read you a little
thing that it seen me that the guys in
general should have been called the
Virginia monologues because it's a lot
of genuine standing around talking not
evenly buddy listening in the audience
or even if it doesn't don't think either
but I sort of sum up my idea of what
robert e lee was like my sense of him by
it I wrote this book before Gods and
Generals came out and I reach this
little paragraph Gods and Generals
promises what should be easily the best
movie portrayal of Lee by Robert Duvall
this is a rare case of the actors being
less beautiful than the historical
character but the prospect is still
exciting I want to envision a Lee and
whom Duvall brings together aspects of
the hard-riding stall work twinkle in
the eye Augustus McCrae in Lonesome Dove
the steely recessive on Italian
conciliate in The Godfather
the truly and personally religious
volatile freelancing preacher in the
Apostle the horsey daughter loving
exasperating father and something to
talk about the overbearing military
father in the Great Santini the kind
manly female friendly father in ramblin
rose the spooky but decent Boo Radley
and To Kill a Mockingbird
the trouble is Duvall won't have much to
work with when it comes to the course
selfish aspects that make those
characters so tangy the film is said to
focus primarily on Stonewall Jackson a
character who enjoyed being himself I
wish I could believe that Robbie Lee
enjoyed himself more I'm enjoying being
here with y'all if you got any more
questions I'll be glad to answering them
now you study much about the post-war
his work at college yeah I thought that
up he seen me that that's the work that
he was most into was being a college
president he was certainly a much better
president of a college than grant was
president of you know
States and he was Hardy deleting at one
point while he was president of Ben
Washington colleagues went on to be
Washington Utley Washington really when
he's now Washington and Lee he was
regarded as a sort of a distant iconic
figure on campus and somebody said he
didn't really like much being around
being with men that much but he ran this
college and he was very attentive it
seemed be a very fussy sort of thought
when he was coming out of West Point
back before the war he actually leaned
over backwards for whistlers mother
Whistler the painter was was a cadet at
West Point when relie was in charge of
it and he was a terrible cadet and
clearly was trying to get kicked out so
he could go to Paris and be a crazy
painter I mean he was saying he had
hundreds of debates and at one point
whistlers mother who lived in Scarsdale
wrote to Lee
she was Lee wants things she had some
special underwear or something to send
to Whistler and Leasing oh he's not
really supposed to take special
underwear but there's some woman okay
and she wrote asking if if Jimmy
Whistler could come and see her goodbye
she went off to Europe and he said well
you know we're trying to keep Jimmy at
school here and over there it's just so
painful but finally they had to give up
on Jimmy because he didn't show up for
things and he won exam they asked him to
define tungsten and he said tungsten is
a gas that was the last straw so another
I don't know why but but Lee will but he
was a good sort of in loco parentis sort
of person fairly it took a real interest
but there's one moment when he's in
Washington
he's head of Washington College a
student who had been a soldier in the
war in the Confederate Army
came to him and was just working himself
to death and Lee said you're overworking
don't grow you go
don't spoil your health you got time
you'll get to college and the this guy
said I'm trying to make up at the time I
lost in the war and League turn he would
get every now and then Lee would get his
blood up anything at Gettysburg
Christmas but his cheeks turned red and
he said don't ever say that the time you
spent in the Confederate Army was the
most profitable years you'll ever spend
don't ever say you wasted time in the
Confederate Army which didn't make much
sense I mean they were certainly not
profitable years were elderly or for
anybody else that i noth except for
certain Union generals who came out
pretty well but I mean Lee lost his
entire fortune and he lost his health in
the war and yet he was determined to say
that it was a good experience
when he was dying there are all sorts of
you know legendary things he's supposed
to say when he's dying but I forget the
exact words that's terrible forget buddy
right according to medical according to
the doctors one of the last things he
said was I'm feeling better
what [ __ ] probably was trying to make
the doctors feel better that was changed
me what Robert Easley was like poor guy
I wrote a book called V sweet memoir
called be sweet which I complained about
the fact that my mother kept telling me
to be sweet I know how to be sweet you
know how you'd easily especially if
you're not made of sugar and spice and
everything nice but see me that Robbie
Lee was somebody who deeds sweet as a
mother would want him to be and then
very miserable I think if you ask me
well question them would you comment on
his role and dissuading southern
officers from fighting a protracted
guerilla war
the hostilities yeah that's one of the
reasons people gave him so much credit
reasonably enough for for being a
unifying figure after the war was that
he discouraged his lieutenants from
continuing the war as guerrillas acts
you know he said now don't do that it'll
just you know he's minute been through
enough with all didn't do enough then he
said well you young officers do what you
will but I'm going to I'm old I'm going
to surrender tomorrow at Appomattox
I think that the you know there's a
whole book called April or something was
a book about how great things are great
that was theory it's easy that he would
say that partly cuz he was not a war
lover and partly because he didn't have
any reason to respect guerrilla warfare
I mean his he had dealt with militias
and dealt with badly trained troops and
he and when he went to capture John
Brown there all these militias gathered
around and all these local people
shooting and causing trouble and Lee
came there and said okay commander the
militia would you like to lead the
charge and they said no only think the
professional soldiers on subject said
how about you Virginia no we will let
you lead the charge he was a
professional soldier and he had no wish
to it had fewer amateur soldiers under
him to begin with ego and didn't you
know when he was in western Virginia at
the beginning of the war trying to pull
together politician generals he had
reason to see how you know you ought to
be either a soldier or an autosome and
so that was a great they do
he left the I mean without going of
course he left the continuation of the
war as guerrilla warfare to Jesse James
who was an ex Confederate soldier who
continued to work in a unhelpful sort of
way
oh thank you very much Robert Ely is
published by Vikings penguin lives
series visit penguin Putnam com for more
information next week on public lives
Evan Thomas discusses his biography of
Revolution